what needs to happen as far as Dominic
Raab is concerned in the interim well he
should be suspended from his job I think
viewers will be shocked that these
hugely serious allegations up to 24
allegations we're told of of bullying
um and he's still serving
um at the very least he should be
suspended pending this inquiry and there
is a question mark over Richard sunuck
himself you know 100 days into his job
he had a very bad appointment of swella
bravaman who had broken the ministry or
a code and he put her back in office we
know now about Nadeem zahawi he he
apparently had been told about the tax
problem for the former now chairman of
the conservative party and now he's he's
not suspending he's Deputy Prime
Minister with these serious allegations
I think the question marks are now not
just about Dominic Robb but about the
Prime Minister but we we heard from
Downing Street this morning actually
they say principal dictates that
ministers carry on with their duties
while any investigation is ongoing well
um I have to say the it wouldn't happen
in a normal job with it
um if you were a civil servant if you
were a journalist if you were in so many
walks of life if the level of these
allegations very serious allegations
made you would you would you were given
gardening leave you wouldn't be at your
desk and you know they are of that
gravity that I really think the Prime
Minister should suspend Dominic Robb we
smoke uh Jacoby smog says beware of
snowflakeery
well that's a classic Jacob Reese MOG
comment completely out of touch with
reality I mean that's the problem with
this government I don't think they
understand real people's lives whether
it's the cost of living whether it's
happening in HS and how you should
behave to your employees uh jQuery smog
typifies the Rishi sunat government that
they they're not in touch with reality
yeah
of government isn't that you know people
like Dominic Robb having to make
critical decisions in the moment he
needs to be able to express himself to
his close team
I was a cabinet minister and I served
under real pressure you should treat
everybody with respect and frankly the
best way to get the best out of your
civil servants isn't to to bully them
but to thank them and I found that was
the best way uh treat people with
respect and you can work as a team and
you can get best results if you shout
and scream at people surprising enough
you won't get the best out of them
proven guilty as well aren't you he's
the Justice secretary and you know who
he that nothing has been found against
him at this stage no I'm I'm more than
willing to wait till the uh KC has been
in charge of this review uh reports to
make the Judgment uh but I still the
king's Council a lawyer yeah the Kings
have a bigger part
um but I I do think in the meantime he
should be suspended because the
allegations are so serious and it again
it it goes to the weakness of the Prime
Minister he's not prepared to take the
action when faced with the facts and you
know one of the things we'd like to see
is the independent minister of advisor
on ethical standards look into what the
Prime Minister knew and when with
respect to these allegations of bullying
against Dominic Robb did he appoint
Dominic Robb knowing these serious
allegations were there
um talk to me about the social care
announcement so many of our viewers this
morning will have seen uh you appearing
in our Jason Farrell's report 200
million pounds being offered to put this
plan into effect
um is that enough money
it's nowhere near enough I mean I
welcome that there's some movement at
long last but independent analysis has
shown we need two billion pounds over
the next four years to start putting
some of this this Scandal right I mean
there are children out there people who
in care in Care Homes people who uh
children who are not being looked after
properly and that should be a scandal
now Society these young people are some
of the most vulnerable in our society
um their whole lives will be blighted if
they're not treated proper as a child
and a young person and one thing that
little Democrats want to do is not just
about money it's about the system and
I've been a strong advocate of
supporting kinship carers and my liberal
Democrat colleague vanira Wilson has put
forward a set of proposals a proposed
law that would give kinship careers
grandparents uncles aunts brothers and
sisters close uh relatives to the young
person when the parent can't take care
give them more rights and more support
that must be the Way Forward where
you're supporting the family and the
fact that government doesn't doesn't
seem to get that is quite shocking and
we have a kinship care actually on the
program later on to talk to us in more
detail about this now Boris Johnson
never far from controversy as we know
said yesterday that anyone who suspects
he covered up lockdown parties while PM
is out of their mind are you out of your
mind
I think I think it's more likely Boris
Johnson owes money he's in total denial
isn't he you know the thing about Bryce
Johnson right and the reason why I think
he behaves so shockingly with those
parties in in number 10 allegations of
sex in the basement during his time
there you know
um I I thought him we have to not not
him but you know he was in number
tenants his building uh and he allowed
these parties this Behavior to go on
during lockdown when everyone else is
abiding by the rules the fact that he he
says that shows that he just deceased
himself just as much as he sees the rest
of the world
um the National Audit office examining
the decision to spend 220
000 pounds of taxpayers money for the
prime minister's legal defense bill
um
if it's proven that some of the delay in
him cut this coming to the fore was as a
result of Mr Johnson's actions should he
be expected to pay some of that money
back
well I think he really needs to be held
to account better than happened so far
you know I personally think he was unfit
for office from day one I was shocked
the conservative party uh put him into
into power and the way he then treated
so many people and lied so so many
people and made such a hash of being
prime minister is actually staying on
the conservative party and although he's
now been thrown out not before time I
think he needs to be fully held to
account and all these various
investigations that there are now into
what happened need to conclude and
whatever the recommendations they come
for with I think they should be
implemented